it's time to babble the [ __ ] on it's
Hollywood babble-on
with your hosts Kevin Smith and Ralph
Garman it's Sunday night in the
Hollywood so let's babble the [ __ ] on
man I'm Kevin Smith I'm Ralph Garman oh
is Babylon from home the way it'll be
for the self quarantined Babylon here we
are socially distancing ourselves from
you but still bringing y'all the same
show we would've brought you if you
could cuddle actually it's we're much
funnier in real life you know what it is
the dynamic of a home show versus a live
show is at a home show you're just
trying to amuse yourself or any other
person yes out there like we're trying
to get 200 save if you're doing the
Improv see 200 200 disparate
personalities to like-minded enough to
be like we're here watching you [ __ ]
but like 200 different senses of humor
laugh at the same time a lot often oh
yeah they like the frequency if we get
one good laugh at today's show we'll be
okay with that you can't do that when
200 people are staring at you like make
with the funny [ __ ] that fast my two
drinks I'll sit here I understand it
completely
I don't do I'm not complaining at all I
just think it's [ __ ] fascinating that
it does result in two different versions
very much of the show in this version of
the show I sound more like me and I
think likewise and in that version of
the show I sound more like an idiot that
you're just performance cap yes I mean
I'm trying to make people happy yes I
remember I remember
[ __ ] what was it poltergeist - Craig
T Nelson was talking to the guy who
played chief and one flow of the
Cuckoo's now yeah right well Samson yes
and he was just like carsick
Craig gene else goes car sick make car
happy oh they can get away with that
anymore new no sir I me the old guy in
that movie yeah are your parents home
that was like one of the last things
that's from your doorman I did before he
died yet through the screen door do you
I hope I live long enough and somebody
out there goes yeah he looks [ __ ]
scariest [ __ ] that they give me some
kind of late in life horror movie role
yeah remember the guy who was in
phantasm Angus Scrimm Angus no it's not
um dude he that was no like late life
like he did that for 30 [ __ ] years
lived off that but it was that look that
that's sold him that's true too creepy
look but like just the guy in
poltergeist 2 was just old yeah that was
somebody's literally probably somebody's
grandfather right and sometimes probably
a leading man in silent films or
something think so
probably you'd probably been in his
whole life and he finally aged into a
look that earned it and it's like play
cards right if there's a [ __ ] movie
industry when this is all over no but if
we ever went back in time to a time
before the virus
you get couple you got Apple man BC
before coronavirus it's true
you could uh you could be old and still
[ __ ] like catch on you know like you
know [ __ ] the other day I'm gonna
[ __ ] name-drop weirdo masters in the
universe record Stephen root comes in I
love him oh I love Stephen rope he's
been a couple things I've done yeah he's
been in a movie with you that um he has
residue at stake em was he in well yeah
reboot he does voices and reboot again
afterwards and did a bunch of voice-over
and rebooted and stuff but I loved him
since Jimmy James and news rain in any
event Milton quarts of corn office and
other people's stuff I love them yeah
yeah I start putting them iced
- but he's a college kid took my stapler
put my tape lay down it's a good [ __ ]
it's a good [ __ ] Milton yeah well
then um I don't need Stephen anymore I
got you he he he came in and [ __ ]
rocked it he's an amazing Cringer the
exact thing spirit of the thing but
while also bringing like you know a
brilliant actors perspective to a big
green freaky cat right
probably and in one of those human
performances of a big green cat you
liver I think it's probably safe to say
hearing all of animation comes in fog of
rocks about a big better move learn from
a pro and out he goes he's done in like
maybe twenty five minutes somebody in
the room was like guy he's great and I
don't know why I find somebody was just
like ball aged came up and I was just
like oh how old do you think he is and
they're like fifty five or something
like that that was a quick hit the
internet Steven Ruud is 68 I think
really yeah let me double check I want
to make him older but and right now I'd
say that because any actor or actress
worth their salt would love to be Steven
root for sure have Steven roots [ __ ]
career man six I'm sorry did I miss
68 god it was right November he'll be 69
huge he's born in Sarasota we wish your
birthday uh November 17 17th
that's your birthday yeah he was born in
51 but you were born 164 he's got you
about 13 years now but in person like
Stevens not even a guy that it's like oh
look at him he's trying to [ __ ] look
young like you know I [ __ ] surgery or
[ __ ] hair or whatever the [ __ ] but in
person he just looks 55 [ __ ] 68
that's something to be said for living a
[ __ ] life where you do exactly what
you want to be doing man and you're
happy doing it no in youth Josh joy is
the Fountain of Youth it really is it's
Ralph what was the thing you said before
that I was like that's something you
never have
first before we get there let's set it
up this week it in entertainment news
yes because that's what we do here's
where we go abalone in news that was
close to home it kind of close to home
yeah I met a young Ralph Garman years
ago when Iced
into the k-rock Morning Show Kevin and
bean and promote things that's how me
and Ralph met and and then after like
since we like comics and stuff a lot of
the same similar things we enjoyed and I
would never leave whenever he would
start the ralph rapport that was like my
favorite show this show biz beat my bed
I mean I guess now there's no there is
no difference they're not coming for you
now or though they might now by that
step lightly is there our openings we
met at a rock that's why the only reason
we get to holla battle on we have made
it's safe to say we've been doing
Babylon 4 it's coming up on the 10th
anniversary ten years obviously the next
live show into the summer beginning the
fall will be our Babylon tenth
anniversary show that everybody can go
to so it is safe to say I'm not being
gross or bragging but safe to say over
all that time we've probably made
million dollars
you think from live shows from ads over
a decade maybe yeah from you know what
I'm saying like thinking about it yeah
and I'm not on the math but that's
pretty nice that we that's him that's a
million we build a million dollar
industry right like our parents would be
so [ __ ] proud they would that isn't
that wouldn't happen if Ralph didn't
work at Cairo true years ago two years
ago yeah Ralph was very unceremoniously
let go of by the station in a shitty way
at a shitty time yes it was at a time
when the whole world was not reading
about the coronavirus they were reading
about the human virus of all these me
two cases right and so all sudden Ralph
was allowed to say this is my last iron
k-rock you know you guys been a great
audience thank you and barely allowed
this that's my time everybody
and off you went and it was just so like
what the [ __ ] you can't sit like you do
that you don't get to people might like
draw conclusions incorrect conclusions
that he's being let go because this
because a lot of people were losing
their jobs at the time for with a sexual
assault and and the like yet and so I
was like that ain't the case OK ROCK
fired Ralph's shitty fair to say yes
just like they had fired Lisa May shitty
yes and you know when we say k-rock it's
an ever-shifting you know a group of sue
people veteran chart make choices yeah
knock obviously an entity k-rock is not
like an alien that came down from space
I will give you those are MK Rock and
DJs and wiener roasts they they fired
two people off the Kevin be a morning
show of his shitty way being one half of
the long term
Kevin beam morning show they've been
there since 1990 so thirty years there
in the broadcaster Hall of Fame yep
being left a couple months back he he's
all he's been me left a while ago he's
up and physically left a while ago yeah
he worked out of Washington State in an
island called Vashon Island off of
Washington State and then moved to
Louisiana and did the show from New
Orleans for years are you [ __ ] me
no some of the last few years he'd been
in New Orleans yeah alright so then he
was like I'm out and he went to England
yeah moved to London
cuz didn't he have like British roots or
something he was born there because his
father was in the military so he was
born when his father was stationed in
the UK you have a dual path I believe he
had dual citizenship yeah [ __ ] sweet
right that's pretty sweet so something
to like whip out when you were in school
like I'm British hello you don't sound
British look at my [ __ ] badge I can
be base or I can be this I'm two
different things
in one you can be a Brit or you can be a
rap you can be a bit or you can be a so
just this week you know Kevin and bean
show stop being coming to being it was
Kevin in the mornings with Ali who
replaced Lee
Lisa and Jensen carpool replaced Ralph
Jensen we know and love gallery 1988
runs the art gallery out here fun may
not remember we hired Jensen to work on
the Hollywood babble-on pilot remember
we said I sent him out in the field to
do the well piece field pieces for us he
back in the day for the rapt enthusiasts
Jensen of course was hot Karl yeah so in
any event Kevin and and and Ali and
Jensen and beer-mug and producer Dave
Dave the King of Mexico and chip gone
yeah oh ship had left already
yeah ship dodged a bullet yeah support
staff everyone got [ __ ] fired with a
phone call during this coronavirus
Christ yes while they were already
having them stay at home because they
didn't want they wanted him to be
socially distancing k-rock you know for
years the Kevin be a morning show was
like the number one [ __ ] show not
only in Los Angeles but by some
demographics yeah America right because
I had set in terms of money-making
stations yeah because la is either one
or two in terms of the largest market in
radio depending on new york in LA and
whatever the numbers are at the given
time and so if you're a top of one of
those two markets you tend to generate
more ad revenue than any other station
in the nation and they had they held
that record for one so there was a time
where you know it was like man [ __ ]
[ __ ] those people [ __ ] k-rock and you
know some people were like yeah but we
still work here and some people were
like yeah but I'm still gonna listen and
stuff like that Ralph went off and
created the Ralph report I've been doing
that for two years and [ __ ] built his
own [ __ ] thing then [ __ ] everyone
got fired and now everyone is like oh
[ __ ] a rock for real right yeah yeah it
trended all day long ya know la radio
station any hardcore listeners who held
there knows when Lisa got let go or and
then stopped their feet by kept
listening when I got let go this seems
like the death now that everyone sort of
abandoning
like you know I know they got rid of
those three guys but I don't know like
six am I like the time of day I gotta
stay listening they should I feel bad
for the striker and whom Klein got to
take over that slot yeah I mean there
are yeah they do afternoons now and
they're moving them into the room so it
might not be too bad but it's like
regardless they could be the most
brilliant broadcasters and they're
wonderful but you you move into a slot
that was been occupied for thirty
[ __ ] years there's a lot of love and
a lot of hard feelings there too a lot
of hard feelings particularly guys oh
yeah yeah [ __ ] even if they called me
and they were like you want what if they
called you in this moment in time and
said [ __ ] come back and and and blank
yeah Kay Rolf okay okay Ralph will
[ __ ] will go out of our way [ __ ] cuz
you you're it you're the [ __ ] you are
the like you're how we hold on to the
past and do the future because like you
know podcast your podcast boy aren't you
hot boy boy boy pod kids right again you
know what you dog you got a foot in the
past on foot in the future that sounds
like radio speak I would imagine
somebody would [ __ ] come sniffing
around to come to work at k-rock again
yeah yeah oh no I couldn't do it why
well here's the thing
having done this with you and watching
your career and your template in terms
of how to create your art and be your
own boss and then having been fired once
by these people and then being my own
boss with the Ralph report and
establishing this amazing audience
called the called the garmi who supports
each other and me and I've been able to
make a living with this I'd be
hard-pressed to work for anybody else
again let alone somebody who had done me
dirty and then done everybody I've ever
worked with dirty in the same way it
would be I don't think I could do it a
different me might have said well [ __ ]
it it's a job and if they're offering me
the right price I'll go in but sometimes
as you get older you start your
priorities start to shift and you say
you know what life's too [ __ ] short
and I'm just not going to put myself in
that vulnerable position again did I see
on Twitter that your subscriptions for
the Ralph report went up
yes significantly now and you could that
that has to do with it has to do two
things one we talked about it
extensively last week when we did our
heads about and a lot of people come and
said oh you know I forgot that you were
doing that all right I just I didn't
know you were doing that so we got a lot
of our babble fans who came over and
then when the news hit with k-rock a lot
of those people said you know what I had
listened to your cajun fries oh that you
put out and I knew you were there and I
feel bad because I didn't really commit
because you know I listened to the
morning show and I only have so much
time I might commute another like [ __ ]
it
this is the time I'm pulling the trigger
and I'm on board it's it's it's garmi
strong and they they signed up so we got
a ton of people who said that's the last
straw I'm crossing over and I'm gonna be
I want to be part of the Grammy know um
I mean it's like you know it sucks that
[ __ ] everyone had to lose their jobs
but it's nice that [ __ ] some people
for the listeners who are like that's
the thing it's and in all this you know
we always talk about like the people
that lost their jobs and stuff
rightfully so but the people oddly
enough who never really get talked about
in this story who are profoundly
affected are the listeners especially in
a time of crisis and anxiety yeah you
want comfort and familiarity you want to
be able to turn on the radio and be like
alright Kevin's are you stalking Halle I
got gonna Janson my friends in the
morning that's its consistency its
consistency its normalcy its it's a
sense of comfort because my radio pals
are there to get me through at least my
morning you know and a lot of people who
have come on and then sent me a quick
email saying I subscribed I'm here now
they said almost to a person it's so
nice to hear your voice again and Monday
through Friday I have you now in my back
pocket and it's nice thing I have you
they don't have it with a podcast
imagicon solo shows up blows them out of
the [ __ ] sky let's blow this thing
and go home kid let's go home and then
we'll blow these things together they've
said that you know they don't have to
know more that instance you've lost a
subscriber
because Han Solo blasted him off your
way it's good point [ __ ] see how Star
Wars from a different perspective seeing
so much but does something like that a
movie one day what about the one of the
Empire podcasters who's counting on
those pilots to be part of this is
subscription base you know who's where's
the you and me talking about on Babel
last week about the people who like do
sports commentary yeah yeah it's so
weird I I've been haunted by that all
week I've been thinking about like what
if I was what if all I had to talk about
was sports thank God all I ever talk
about is Kevin Smith because not going
anywhere open all night kids 24/7 365
but if I was like dependent on like you
know [ __ ] you see that game about
comic books and Marvel and DC just said
we're not printing comic books anymore
there are a lot of people who must be
going through a real existential crisis
right now
not just a financial one but one more
Mike who am i if I'm not speaking about
what others do who the [ __ ] am i I'll
tell you one thing right now there's the
the but even though the convict the
quarantines changed much for me excited
to sit around the house most days anyway
when I can Chen did not go out and stuff
but I have noticed like more of an
increase in like I guess I went out more
like I go out for massages and I go to
veggie grill and stuff so now with time
war on the house I'm like I should
stream and I was ant like this morning I
got up and I was like I must dream about
Kenny Rogers and I wound up being like
an hour stream on YouTube not just
trying out the platform is it worked out
nicely but at the same time I'm like why
am I doing this and I really thought
about it and I'm like oh the same reason
you literally do everything you know
publicly or anything professionally and
stuff like that relevancy like you know
I've been seeing a lot of people like my
wife this morning was like Michael Stipe
did a [ __ ] livestream concert man
thought that was really cool as I get a
lot of people are doing that she goes I
know but this one affected me like this
one was for me instead
was it it's a one lucky I guess vase
time go look into that yeah she might
have met my cat meow or some some [ __ ]
I'm like you pay for this how much that
cost
[ __ ] so like yeah you know I know there
are some people who are like oh that's
[ __ ] beautiful like they're gonna
play concert for somebody and it is
beautiful that's nice but at the root of
it really is the same reason why I let
go like I'm gonna do livestream like I'm
still here you just want to make sure
the people still noticed you're
screaming into the void is so wonderful
slash horrible being a creative because
you you really at the end of the day
like well I have a wife and child bro
and still at the end of the day I'm like
how does this affect me and my ability
to tell stories to people we will talk
about that very issue at the end of
today's show when we wrap up with a
segment that we usually wrap up the live
show with and that was my point exactly
about that story so we'll we'll put a
pin in that and we'll circle all the way
[ __ ] around yeah um but the point we
were trying to get to star blazer sorry
was that when they gave me the boot over
two years ago at Cairo host all these
people lost their jobs in the worst
possible time in world history to be
unemployed yes in a time where the
economy is tanking and we're all
paralyzed with fear about a virus that
we know very little about that we don't
know whether it's gonna be it's gonna
wipe us out or whether it's gonna be
another that was that was a drag a lot
of people died but somewhere in between
or some whatever was nothing but
uncertainty right so now these people I
mean Kevin whatever he's fine game
writer Kevin Ryder from Kevin bean show
he made a very good living for a long
time I've sure he's put a few bucks away
he's not in trouble but the board ops
and the people who were living check to
check at that show they were also
shit-canned gone and I couldn't help but
think in retrospect and I was so unhappy
and panicked
Canha miserable when they let me go over
two years ago I thought that was the end
of my life what am I gonna do now oh
this is great cuz this is the thing I
wanted to get to and I got somebody in
the room is not a stone designed to get
us back to the point cuz mouse said
something that's coming up kids I just
want to just want to remind you that
we're about to conclude a thought we
started 20 minutes ago flee to
conversate it's gonna be worth it watch
he's gonna stick the landing and you're
gonna go that was [ __ ] good the
perspective of that event changed so
profoundly for me and I said I was on a
cruise ship and they pushed me overboard
at the time it felt like they were
pushing me overboard and they did but I
they pushed me into a lifeboat
oh come on say let's make it shorter so
that everyone could say it we can put on
bumper sticker and a t-shirt maybe even
a magnet they I thought I got pushed me
over I thought they were no because they
did push it I got pushed overboard but I
fell into a life when I fell into a
lifeboat so so anyway there's no
attention but if you break the metaphor
down then pushing you who pushed you
overboard
the powers would be a k-rock right so
how much me they pushed me over the rail
and they said get off the ship you're
gonna you're gonna drown right but what
they didn't know was wait so whether
they did it for your own good like you
no no no they threw me off the ship to
drown me they think they were jettison
me we're getting rid of all the all the
unnecessary unnecessary weight right
you're ballast we're throwing you
overboard holy [ __ ]
caramel cruise ship it's the worst I
would never go on it again and the
buffet by the way was not that good they
threw me overboard but I landed in a
lifeboat because I was able for two
years to go off and build my show and
establish this audience and create this
relationship and then that goddamn
cruise ship went down and I'm in the
lifeboat looking from my island oh yeah
your honor you have your own Island yeah
[ __ ] trade around I'm watching it
just blah blah blah blah blah gone what
a beautiful guy's head I lost my head I
stayed on this show if they'd kept me
around and I've lost my job
let's do the altar alright what if time
line you have not two years you've still
been a k-rock right and and the and the
numbers haven't been good in the ratings
are sinking and everyone's starting to
panic and then they give me that phone
call and they say you're done the night
before and now I'm left we're in a time
of uncertainty and panic when no one is
hiring and no one is interested in
anything but staying at home with their
loved ones and washing their hands how
do you how do you get people's attention
at that moment and say I'm still alive
come with me on this journey you know it
just it wouldn't it wouldn't it wouldn't
happen or would be remarkably difficult
so what sounded like you know [ __ ]
the end of my career was the beginning
of a new chapter that has actually been
more satisfying than anything I could
have imagined here man you keep talking
I'm gonna try to find a clip apply that
metaphor falling off the boat right
ain't it fall I didn't fall off the boat
man I got pushed off the boat I got
thrown overboard applied to into a life
some is somebody who doesn't work in our
business and didn't get fired from
k-rock and build the ralph report
because that's very specific
circumstances but yes still feels like
that metaphor could apply to others
right it's let's say you're working at
Walmart okay and they shitcan you for no
reason no fault of yours okay
hmm and you think I've worked and retail
my whole life and that's all I know
and nobody is hiring what am I gonna do
and then on your Street there opens up a
little corner store mm-hmm for a good a
good rent and you go in there and you
open your own hardware store and it
becomes a huge success or you know
you're working for a supermarket and you
start your own mom-and-pop bakery or you
do whatever it is that you do and love
to do but you get to do it on your own
terms in your own place and you're the
boss and no one can fire you that is
magic
if you can if you can make that happen
it's it's a gift and the thing is
sometimes you don't make that happen
until you have to
it may not have been a choice if they
kept you at Walmart or they kept you at
that grocery store for the remainder of
your career and gave you a gold watch
when you retired they forced you to do
something out of your comfort zone
because at the time it seemed like a
really shitty thing was happening to you
but in reality it forced you into a new
chapter that that ended up being so much
better than it could have been um so
beautifully put and I keep looking for
this part you know would I have quit
k-rock to go off and do my own podcast
and start my own mock podcast show and
then hopefully still moving forward and
network perhaps and what I've entered
into that world willingly leaving the
comfort of a steady paycheck and knowing
where my next meal was coming from in a
radio station probably not because I'm
not necessarily that ballsy a guy
especially when you got a wife and kid
you know and when when you when the
choices when the choices you make affect
the lives of those that you love much
more so even than yourself you know and
that was the situation I was in I had a
kid and I had to take care of her and
what do I was gonna do so and so that's
how those Ralph report was born you
built your own thing yeah like as
opposed to I work for somebody and that
somebody could yank my life out from
under me yeah like fool me once shame on
I mean it was even time after after they
let me go that I interviewed at other
radio stations and other radio
conglomerates and companies saying do
you have anything they're like we love
your work man but we just don't have
anything right now
and so I I was literally in a corner at
the time I thought it was the worst
thing that could happen I mean and to
being the best thing so sometimes a
little distance in your life changed
your perspective the point where you
don't even realize you were getting
blessed when you thought you were being
cursed this is a little piece of
dialogue from Charlie Wilson's War the
featuring the great Tom Hanks and the
late great Philip Seymour Hoffman that
tells a little story is written of
course by Aaron Sorkin he does okay and
with words and it tells the exact
gesture time listen not for nothing but
do you know the story about there's a
master and a little boy boys some from
nits of the Greek which have a quill
with the Pennsylvanian yeah and a matter
of fact is there's a little boy you know
as 14th birthday gets a horse everybody
in the village says how wonderful the
boy got a horse and the Zen master says
we'll say two years later the boy falls
off the horse breaks his leg and
Rabinowitz says how terrible a Zen
master says we'll see then war breaks
out and all the young enough to go off
and fight support Kings as legs all
messed up and everything the village
says how wonderful and then master says
we'll see so you get it hmm yep it's
true you can never like it all seems in
the moment [ __ ] horrible or good yeah
yeah that's the other thing too like
when you're like oh my god [ __ ]
everything's coming up millhouse right
see and in that moment but Elvis thought
he was the luckiest little boy from
Tupelo until he died on the [ __ ]
facedown in the shag carpet yeah but I
mean wasn't he out of 42 was that how
old he was at the time we all felt like
oh that old man Elvis died he was seven
years older than Elvis was when he
passed yeah how is that possible I
thought like Elvis was my mom's age no
well I mean I guess he would have been
if he
yeah those how long's he been dead now
30 years 77 I think he died my mom still
has a Christmas ornament for this from
his death oh I remember when he died
like my mom bought this Christmas when
I'm at home and you know I was like gave
his birth date and death date and this
him from like the Hawaii pure blue who I
period or write write the tour that come
back to her yeah yeah and four years man
for the next 10 Christmases were more
than I spent in the house I always
occurred to me as a really god [ __ ]
Christmas wanna remember him but little
boy from Tupelo whose dreams come true
or did they who will see on the route
report
we'll see he's so [ __ ] brilliant
Philip Seymour Hoffman yeah and one of
the best impressions that Kevin Smith
does can't bring him up without doing a
little Philip Seymour Hoffman for us
yeah wife daughter so I'm gonna find her
i'ma find her and the killer I'm gonna
kill you right in front of her who are
you what's your name
let's [ __ ] watch [ __ ] me doing it now
that I'm hooked up to this thing is
we're not gonna play clips from movies
right yeah Philip Seymour Hoffman and
beacon in movies I have a business idea
for you whether you'd be interested or
not okay let's open a drive-in
done and done drive-in movie theaters
are the only movie theaters that are
open oh my god you're right it's so
weird you said that my agent texted me
last night he was going what about a
drive-in tour and I was like yeah I'm
always up for that and he goes no for
the coronavirus he's going cuz that way
everyone's socially isolated you still
do sit in your car and you can still do
your thing I was like oh my god you're
right we could show movies and [ __ ]
IQA the only movie theaters that are
left we need what do we need to fly
through a tour in about a week by the
way I don't think how many out of there
could be open one I was yes I was we
should right now we find a piece of
property and open it up put up a screen
can't we rent like a firing line like
they do for Christmas trees and be like
for the next six months it's a goddamn
drive-in movie theater I don't know how
that kind of thing works but I bet
there's money in it look into it man
hold on yeah I get to that [ __ ]
Mission Possible oh my god it's great
and everything this is [ __ ] YouTube
cuz they really just they queue it up
for Oh what do you die for I was into
overdose
[Music]
now how is this brilliant seen only a
minute and 48 seconds like it better go
deeper than I like this better be the
whole [ __ ] scene but if it isn't like
I watched you know during the [ __ ]
coronavirus like I'm uh you know I'm I'm
watching a lot of [ __ ] that I didn't
have time to watch right there's whole
categories on YouTube where it's like
families on a [ __ ] text chain and
it's like how can I shut my family off
movie clips round my loved ones so I can
get more Philip Seymour Hoffman I don't
care what my daughter has to say I want
to see Mission Impossible she's trying
to foster a [ __ ] animal [ __ ] my wife
is long distance animal fostering well
she wants to do it in person
meanwhile I'm like I just want to hear
see more often but it's only a minute
and forty I mean less because it's where
five seconds into a minute and forty
seconds I hope this goes the distance
let's see oh my god I [ __ ] love this
scene JJ Abrams yeah
he hasn't even spoken yet this can't be
the whole [ __ ] sea 13:14 breaking up
he's looking around my [ __ ] you came
see cuz my family here's texting about
functional Tom Cruise has some [ __ ]
that's my honest whatever that's not
what we're here for and I love Tom
Cruise I know you do I'm a cruise guy
inexplicable that was you in the
bathroom I haven't you know tell us
everything cruise control every buyer on
the fork twist every organization what
the hell is your name names contacts
inventory list uh my wife girlfriend
except to you how this goes maybe see
know what I'm gonna do next
I'm gonna find her whoever she is I'm
gonna find it I'm gonna hurt her
you're apprehended carrying details of
the location something codenamed the
rabbit's foot I'm gonna make her bleed
and cry and call out your name and
you're not gonna be able to do [ __ ] you
know why
what is it rabbit's foot cuz you're
gonna be this close to dead and I was
spider then I'm gonna kill you right in
front of her I'm gonna ask you one more
time what's your name what is the
rabbit's foot who are you who stood by
her yeah have any idea what the hell's
going on to you I mean so [ __ ]
brilliant where he's like what's your
name who are you like it sounds like a
like your mom you had [ __ ] Kaldor I'm
talking to the lady returns go what's
your name who are you oh the power I
mean I like such a loss losses some but
you know somebody's husband somebody's
dad as a human being seem like a real
nice guy but like to the craft but you
know what we should be happy we got any
Philip Seymour Hoffman a pharmacist and
every one of them is [ __ ] great like
every one of them does something
original and Kevin's gonna pull them all
up on his phone for you oh and Magnolia
remember that scene in Magnolia where he
said that thing doesn't remember his
Boogie Nights Marin Boogie Nights when
he said that thing about that guy
does he have a thing see he's got a big
scene in everything he's Philip Seymour
Hoffman that do you in the Mission
Impossible movies yes where's that one's
staying for it number one I think really
the JJ one yeah that's my favorite I
love it I think it's well done yeah
first once nice cuz it kind of sets up
the universe a Palmer remember when it
was a big deal and a Palme was directing
this Barker and then after him it was
John Woo the second ones that the one
that I have never rewatched cuz it was
so like that was the one where he ripped
off his face 18 - that's right it just
kept happening over I mean yeah I guess
you're like 5 max but this feels like
frequent then the third one I think was
JJ yeah that's my favorite and then we
got into like I like the last what was
pretty dope what's his name Christopher
McQuarrie yes last view
filming Hawaii was filming two
back-to-back it went it went from this
like you know series were the how did
they like its you know how like Madonna
changes all the time and everyone's like
she's told [ __ ] irrelevant cuz she
looked she wears on our patch now like
Jill these pictures that a way to change
you know I rotala boost Stacy as a hat
you buy it one more [ __ ] time they did
that with Mission Impossible they kept
fresh yeah by being like this movie
series ain't about spies it's about how
we're gonna kill Tom Cruise right on
camera [ __ ] we make him hang off of next
he jumped out of a [ __ ] plane for us
what a nut mark he broke his ankle live
on camera it realizes like it's become
the selling point and but but oddly
enough like the movies are better than
that ya know and they're really tight I
watched the movie and I'm like well yeah
I'm like I'm glad he's holding on the
plane that's [ __ ] dope but like won't
you sell me the story the story was
actually really good and the reveals and
the twists are almost always I didn't
see a comment hopes to have the guy that
[ __ ] broke usual suspects no twisting
the knife and [ __ ]
it was ya [ __ ] but still JJ did a
[ __ ] fine job but like how do you
think you know JJ if you go online now
it's very like I don't even know if it's
50/50 but there's a lot of like [ __ ]
yeah cuz a lot of people I guess didn't
care for a rise of Scott Walker yeah
there was some so this might blowback
like be his you know like you did
mission impossible 3 that was the first
thing he did in the movies right yeah
like his jump from alias to backs Tom
Cruise really like to alias right now
the glossed was going on oh yeah sure
so he makes this movie that movie
eventually leads to him making Star Wars
yep which eventually of force awakens
which like [ __ ] 2 billion bucks which
eventually leads him to make him rise of
Scarlett or 1 billion dollars which
[ __ ] a pittance a mere pittance
a success by any measure yes except for
the fact that there's a bunch of the
hardcore constituency that'll like what
the and
mad and like every time a new like the
novelization came out two weeks ago so
much better than the movie why god
[ __ ] it what do you mean she's not
his granddaughter she's a goddamn clone
cuz he's like and what are you saying
one of the clones and Saxon what like so
and I'm not Marga those people it's true
it's just like it adds more dimension
it's you know there seems to be a
general kind of like you know like
everything in this life now two camps
tribalism yes
about those movies and the one camp is
like that's good and the other camp is
like that's not Laura of Star Wars yes
to those who like at its the canceled
culture he must now go away because he
did something I didn't like
so did so duh you know Mission
Impossible is the him getting the horse
that's right yeah and you know people
like how wonderful you got a horse and
some guys like will say okay but still I
bet you at the end of the day even with
the world go on like we're half the
world not even a lot but just bunch
people like going like you didn't do the
thing I wanted you to do I bet you he
but never regrets make it no choice are
you kidding me like [ __ ] I got to make
Star Wars twice so you know else made
Star Wars twice like George Lucas and
that's it
yep I think that's the case that's the
only director of two Star Wars movies
other than George Lucas is that correct
I think you're right Irvin Kershner
Richard Marquand and then the whole next
thing was George George George yeah and
then it was JJ and then Ryan and then
George I mean Ryan will eventually make
another Star Wars movie right my little
boy at the broom [ __ ] his magic which
I know mocking I understand [ __ ] I'll
be careful in this way yeah I know I
ain't we're all home and I don't need
people canceling me at home and [ __ ] I
got nobody else's talked to it's a
problem I enjoy that I love that very
much I'm I love last Jedi
i I've given a wonderful review and I
take a lot of heat for it and stuff but
that the you know magic broom boy was
you know that's Brian will make a whole
universe of those movies but it won't be
the nine movie no star
Skywalker [ __ ] till I say about JJ in
that last film was I
I wouldn't put anybody up to the
challenge of wrapping that storyline
yeah come on
it's so vast and out of control and
there's so many tentacles and everything
else going on with the books and what's
Canon what's not Canon and the animated
series that was the thing with the other
thing don't forget it was also dealing
with like you better fix what they
[ __ ] write in the last one man you
better do it right so you're like
service fans yeah there's a lot of cooks
to feed but then you got to try to tie a
bow around that that animal who could
have done it yeah honestly and I'm not
even just I mean literally even if they
were like we'll give you 20 million
dollars like you get to keep that
the movies gonna cost 200 we're gonna
give you ten percent twenty million
dollars to make this movie and that
means you're gonna have to take all the
[ __ ] heat but you're gonna have 20
million dollars where the tissues to
[ __ ] soap it out and you've made a
Star Wars movie these movies make a
billion dollars regardless and so what
do you say what do you say cop-out what
do you say
[ __ ] tusky you want to do this you
ready step up to the big leagues I swear
to you I'd be like no there's too much
I'm a creature of the internet and I
just know that it's like that's for me
my fragile ass there you go
you know [ __ ] that's too much
pressure and [ __ ] like I get I'd [ __ ]
take [ __ ] for [ __ ] up Kevin Smith
movies could you imagine if I [ __ ] up
Star Wars like if someone else's
intellectual property um and I you know
tell you you don't know how to write for
Jason Mewes
or Silent Bob for that matter but you
know I yeah I couldn't handle that
especially if like you're like but I
didn't [ __ ] up I really feel like I did
a good job I mean I have a hard enough
time with James on bobbery boom people
like what a [ __ ] whiff that was and
like no wasn't like that literally
succeeded like you can take you know and
then I'm like why Mario
so all Star Wars that would have
destroyed me no way and also let's be
honest nobody was offering know they
know who [ __ ] they should be if all
the Star Wars is to fabro he doesn't
know his way around the you watch your
nose you have you watched man alone
I haven't seen any yet please please
take a moment it you know what it feels
like well I'll get I'm gonna tell you
what it feels like and it's gonna
intrigue you it's gonna make you watch
it sooner alright it was literally like
watching a TV show at two o'clock on a
Sunday in the 70s mmm
it was like watching the Planet of the
Apes TV show the whole end credits
sequence feels like the Planet of the
Apes [ __ ] TV show because a series of
drawings they just do the credits and
they move around the drawings and
somebody's drawings of what happened in
the episode oh my oh my god like never
mind the plot and the plots wonderful
stories wonderful the characters are
wonderful a whole [ __ ] thing is just
joy but it feels like a show that you
vaguely remember watching as a child and
that lucky I don't know if it equates
that way for everybody but for me in the
same way that Michael Stipe doing that
concert online was just for Jen and it
hit her and she's like that's for me it
felt like like oh my god like they're
trying to and Favreau's our age yeah so
we share probably the same cultural
references like it's it feels like you
know kung-fu it feels like like [ __ ]
just planned the Apes TV show is what
keeps going over and over in my head
because that was like oh my god we're in
the universe and like they're spending
money granted they want to spend a lot
but it's like right these cats are
spending all the [ __ ] money holy [ __ ]
IG 11 the [ __ ] you know the ig-88
[ __ ] droid right right and bounty
under the title watch TV plays [ __ ]
fantastic makes you want to break open
your Darth Vader [ __ ] action figure
set and pull out your old ig-88 and go
to work
oh it's good and some people like I
finally got around and watching I
tweeted about it [ __ ] and like you got
direct an episode I do not like I don't
want it like I would loved if they put
me in that show that's what I want you
know if you're wishing for anything
[ __ ] get me in the show right but I
they don't need my a bartender they
don't need my quote-unquote help these
[ __ ] have cracked the code and it's
beautiful and not everything that I love
like I don't want to
wanted like do I don't love things and
go like I want to do like [ __ ] like I
you know I love Jason's wife I don't
want to do her you know what I'm saying
I love somewhere only do well I respect
was a good-looking guy I know Jason I'm
saying overhearing a virus or not for me
man it was just like I don't it's so
good I I don't it doesn't make it not
never once when I was watching it was
like oh I'd love to play I'd love it if
I could direct it up so it seems like a
lot of work so when I watch [ __ ] like
that you don't feel that way about
almost anybody's work I'm very rarely
here watching a movie or a TV series
where you're like oh I'd love to get my
hands on that kid those characters yeah
and even when I worked on like flash
that reached out to you it wasn't it was
Jordan reached out I'll write on your
behalf yeah Jordan girl Jordan told boy
Jordan I think girl Jordan is Jason's
wife right who [ __ ] Ralph was I
wasn't hitting on her just admiring her
as a single man there's a single man a
good Meier good-looking lady it's gonna
be amazing when when you're like when we
could get back to the world and you can
truly be a single man and tell us
[ __ ] tale yeah I'm a lady I met me a
lady
what will you do will you be what will
you do yeah like we'll be allowed to you
probably won't use names but will you be
like and you can't risk telling the
story of like oh my god I had sex last
nine years I've they might hear it on
the pockets but you look big and then
you never get through so how are you
gonna gauge it are you gonna give out
the information I think you're like an
astronaut I think off the rough
astronaut yes I'll have to run it past
them and say we do a hole if I don't use
names I don't think most women would
mind we could do a whole thing like that
freaks I plan to get with if you get on
[ __ ] tinder some of the nastier ones
like [ __ ] ass sniffers we said on the
Ralf report this week Swiper no swiping
look here's the thing about I've never
been
patience that women want to [ __ ] by
looking at a picture of they're nice
they're not like oh yeah look at that
hunk I got a game you I'm alone video
clips I don't know I have no idea how
that works Majan you could put up a clip
of you on battle and [ __ ] if I was you
I'd say my famous in one centralized
locality
that's enough nowadays bro that's true
on tick-tocking look spoiler jumbling my
famous john mulaney like when he does
SNL recently when he came out for the
monologue was like I'm like Louis
Farrakhan I'm very important to a very
small group of people
yeah man [ __ ] so going back to the
original point though my [ __ ] good
luck yeah
finding that what was the original point
k-rock know those people well yes but
you built a [ __ ] ship and then a
metaphor and we listen to Charlie Wilson
then we were trying to follow the tether
back down even movies which we were most
recently how they don't exist anymore
I know these happened but when we all
crawl out of our caves when the
primordial ooze comes out of the swamp
oh yeah oh yeah do you think we see more
contagion disease movies disaster borne
episode or less a more I don't want to
see it you're good maybe think of Brian
Lynch cuz he put a funny tweet out this
week he said hey sci-fi yeah pal of ours
who of course is the genius behind
minions and toy Academy's book series
which my kid loves good shout out damn
guts
anyway what is Lady carry his wife you
know he's got a little boy named Henry
would you do [ __ ] well they've got
they're both parents and [ __ ] yeah and
Brian's got his [ __ ] thing in this
animation Empire
Carrie is bhagam wife or you know Brian
her [ __ ] husband carrie has she she's
a her name is in every episode of the
mandalorian she's she's over there she's
got Walker kid but this don't be I don't
know one of those places so she's
involved in everything
Wow and Lynch texted me the other day be
like
because good I was like I thought about
you the other day because I I seen
carey's name and the credits every
episode and stuff and he goes she's on
that show like every day and stuff like
that and never once once did it occur to
me to be like oh well [ __ ] I'm a
director like honestly it seems like a
lot of work and it's also like not it's
my passion to watch those stories not to
tell them my passions to tell my stories
and [ __ ] right and like doing the flash
it's like you're in you're out [ __ ]
nine days and eight days like something
like that and you know and it's a
well-oiled machine that you know like
they doing for a few years so it's like
here's your template do this and stuff
it's a little more freeform seems like
over at the at the mandalorian man each
one had a different flavor style to it
stuff so and I have no flavor or style
so I like I loved watching that [ __ ] but
it never occurs to me even though I'm a
[ __ ] director I never watched that
[ __ ] going oh I want to do that or this
is what I would do different or anything
like that but Lynch tweeted out this
week he said hey sci-fi Network when
this is all over we don't need Cobra
virus or coven 19 why do they send water
because now they're gonna start churning
but funny part was the second episode
but if you're going to do it I'd like to
write in director please and I'm just I
was thinking about that a contagion and
outbreak in all those movies we've kind
of seen there's so much less
entertaining now that we're actually
living it I can't imagine it'll ever be
as much fun to watch this the viral
spread movie again after we've all been
traumatized by the real thing yeah Wow
it's like it's like earthquake movies
when I was a kid living in Philadelphia
and I watched earthquake with Charlton
Heston whoever was the universal show I
thought wow that's awesome and having
been through real earthquakes I no
longer want to see an earthquake movie
it's not entertaining to me anymore but
there's something that we all can now
commonly reference that we all have
familiarity with [ __ ] much
familiarity and kind of like remember
after September 11th then like there's a
respectful five years maybe maybe more I
think
five when imagery that instantly called
that to mind started like wake making
its way into pop culture like I remember
the one of the trailers for like one of
the transformer movies where like
something wrapped itself around a
building in that building like a
gigantic skyscraper and started coming
down that was looks like and then Batman
V Superman of course even before that
[ __ ] the whole last act of Man of
Steel oh yeah that's what I meant is
like literal [ __ ] like we're gonna
destroy the city porn and literally
Bruce Wayne running through the dust and
opening stuff and that's the opening of
B via how that be so I mean and what I
just rewatched that this week too cuz
I'm like well I'm always I'm always
convinced by one day I'm gonna love it
so I'm watching it and you know it does
brilliantly tie in the third act of Man
of Steel - the first act of that movie
yeah it's a nice dovetail but it's the
you know it's the he dove tailed off of
the one part of the movie that most
people were like oh yeah are you sure
that's Superman yeah and you know that's
why I've all respect to Zack he was like
oh it's Superman
and I'm gonna double down on it and
we're gonna build the whole next movie
um open your mouth open your mouth I'm
sticking this in it was it so no that's
that's why I keep watching cuz I'm like
he did his own thing I think you know
why I'm able to kind of not be like
shitty and judgmental or whatever [ __ ]
like in comics you know as a comp agreed
er I spent so many hours reading stories
of the same character through the prisms
of different writers yeah and there are
some people you like oh I love the way
Frank Miller does Batman hmm and there
are some people you like that I mean
they did fine with Batman and then
there's some people are like one [ __ ]
book are they writing yeah and so I
think that that's why I'm able to like
watch those movies comfortably because
I'm like it's just a different writers
take on the subject matter and when I
look at it through that prism I'm like
that you know that's interesting yeah
but you don't get one comic book every
10 years to judge the character with
I mean it's the weight of the enterprise
it's not just how stout of the
characters also affects the future -
yeah because once you set that in stone
okay this is the way we're going now
with this for the next 20 years until
someone else comes and gives another
interpretation I story online that
they're doing Superman shows for Warner
age no matter plus max whatever hmm well
they already got CW's got Lois paper man
although we gotta be careful what we say
what did i do I did [ __ ] fat man
beyond right before we were all crawled
into holes and stuff and at the cantina
and they said you know I read I said oh
I read on the Internet
you know that [ __ ] they might use
daredevil in spider-man 3 or whatever
the corner and then you know [ __ ] on
Monday morning it was Kevin Smith says
yeah that was returning and I had to
tweet up I'm like not for nothing I I
literally read that like you read it on
the internet so I can't
I'm not source I'm just a happy [ __ ]
enthusiastic fan like you and stuff but
the series is happening that's for real
yeah yeah that is happening but then
cement his parents to other ones on HBO
oh really
max mmm they're starting to get loose
with the you know cuz Warner Bros real
tight to some degree with the big uns
yet the big characters like the back
stays in the cave yeah you know you get
to do Batwoman and you're getting close
someone care dude dude robbing a little
bit with Titans over here but you know
angle let you do the Batman show but now
but they've seen how Star Wars has given
Star Wars to Disney Plus and not only
survived but [ __ ] thrived and the
crew made it culturally [ __ ] relevant
and more important or more culturally
relevant and more important than it's
been since like safe words awakens
there's nothing good them even keep
going further but I'd say since force
awakens cuz force awakens like we're
back we're making movies again turn on
the lights of the Dead start [ __ ] right
there with it if not more so is the
[ __ ] invention of baby Yoda yeah like
you cannot [ __ ] quit baby Yoda is
everywhere it's gonna keep coming at you
it's the greatest thing that
can happen to humanity and Star Wars
particularly because suddenly you're
like oh yeah this [ __ ] can capture my
imagination again what a great salesman
for that [ __ ] show yeah like you know
Mandalorian looks cool and shitty show
people baby Yoda you know who's gonna
show up my mom it's gonna watch that
show oh he's so cute looks like my cat
like it was kind of brilliant man so
[ __ ] I love that show no interest in
[ __ ] working on it but being in it
[ __ ] yeah oh my god I'm being in a
heartbeat yeah so you predicted virus
movies I predict virus movies because we
all might hate it yeah I guess it
depends how it turns out - yeah I guess
that was the point right but September
11th movies I think yeah I think yes I
think we are going to see movies because
now we have a common frame of reference
and they're you know that winds up
working its way into like critical I
don't like it not a bit um the question
is will there be [ __ ] you know movies
you see the movie theaters or looking
for a bailout yeah every industry is
airlines travel movies so I'm completely
ignorant hotels you know how we've
bailed out the American government has
bailed out did they bail out the auto
industry what yes and they've also
bailed out the banking industry the
banking industry now because I've never
given socialism much thought yeah I
assume they had to bail out the banks
because like well goddamn it we need
banks yes so that's why you do that yes
so to prop up the US economy if the
banks fail we all fail but the bad thing
was they gave the money and then the
money didn't get used right it was like
I got a [ __ ] bonus and yes and a lot
of golden parachutes and a lot of
buybacks as they called it where they
would buy back their own stock and
things like that there's a lot of shifty
financial goings ons bailing out the car
industry what do you get out of that
that wasn't that was a success for the
most part because it is keep cars in
America keep cars in America keep
American jobs in America and the the car
manufacturers paid back those loans with
interest at one point so that was a that
was a pretty successful enterprise and
so now than the latest 100 the latest
wanted or is every other industry ever
can jump airline industry
yep which cruise line we go tell me I
mean cruise lines daddy threw me off the
boat remember it's for Adam that seems
like a leisurely activity and like I
don't know that I build I mean I don't
wanna [ __ ] piss anybody off but like
I list of like big things that I don't
need to get on the ship to get somewhere
is what you're saying
yeah those days are talking kind of get
on plane I think you do gotta bail out
the airlines for Evan say he's kind of
have to be needed and then nationalize
them then all the [ __ ] affairs come
down nice just like Amtrak done out
there I'm not political at all so please
don't listen to me but the movie
industry not the movie industry but the
exhibition industry right
they have brick-and-mortar theaters have
talked about we want you know save us a
lout save us
where are you staying on it I love movie
theaters I do too I'm sorry maybe that's
old school and maybe cuz I come from a
different generation there's probably a
lot of people say I don't give a [ __ ]
how I digest my content I'll walk it on
my phone I'll watch it on my watch I'll
watch it on a computer screen I'll watch
it on my giant screen in my living room
I don't feel that way I like movie
theaters I like the experience I like
the the the process I like the popcorn I
like the whole nine yards of it as a
taxpayer then you split the bail out of
the theater well yet remembers a lot of
people employed by that industry as well
last time you walked him to him over
there last movie-going experience I had
I did not interact with a human being I
really took it off machine do you do
popcorn do you don't do the concession
stand then I know yeah see I still do
it's crazy I went to a theater I used to
go to in Florida with my mom all the
time and you know just be a box office
window mm-hmm and now the window is just
boarded up but essentially boarded up
and it's just a [ __ ] kiosk where you
buy some tickets see I like the ArcLight
because they're they're just maybe over
staffed with people and God gives the
little spiel ahead of time tells you
about the movie you're gonna see and
tells you turn off your phone and
everything I'm just
spacious you always feel socially
distant anyway at the ArcLight
yeah the I don't know what's gonna
happen to those places honestly
I mean they're only existing now because
of Marvel movies and and the ilk you
know you Jam a lot of people in there
for Blake big blockbusters and that's
what carries them along for the rest of
the year and if that goes away can they
are they you know a concern that can
still operate on the on that principle
having I think maybe they will serve on
it because that experience still of
seeing the Avengers on a big screen or
any of these blockbuster films the Star
Wars films everything that's hard to
replicate even on the best of home
theater situations unless here Kevin
Smith you have a 400 inch screen it's
only 103 yeah man I could there's a
there's a timeline where you know this
never gets better and you know they're
like we can't ever gather in crowds
again right and then the exhibition
everything jury everything we want to
used to and it's a story we're telling
the young ones music around and watch
movies with others they like put how did
how did you not die who had gathered
together in a darkened room is when our
antibodies were strong auntie and uncle
bodies we're going come back it [ __ ] you
I used to I used to command an audience
1500 a night on the Reba road or now
Kevin goes house-to-house in the days of
the crow fire does it outside their
picture like that's not you as yes I
wrote the line having been to a bunch of
theatres on the Jay and Silent Bob
reboot Roadshow to her you know how a
lot of theatres are [ __ ] coping with
like dwindling ticket sales I don't
adding bars yes I'm all for that just
makes sense I raised my hand seems to
you know I haven't seen any give me all
the options I want food drink massages I
want a haircut I want to own a mani-pedi
while I'm watching the movie I want all
of the amazing about the mall I wanted
all over the movie screen they have the
movie theaters usually at the mall they
already have
dreamworld I want it while I'm watching
the movie it's at literally and a
brothel
I want a [ __ ] while I'm watching the
film thank you the Beverly connection
show you your dreams exist you have you
can have everything you want you can
have well the good news is we're all
gonna be saved because this week I have
you saw enough of Justin Bieber was
praying for us did you see this well I'm
look if we're gonna talk about this
[ __ ] we better [ __ ] but he wanted
to old do it we'll do it proper it does
yeah he was on Instagram and he was
praying for us Oh [ __ ] good good I'm
always doing [ __ ] for him it's about
time he gave me some things prayers did
he mention me personally didn't know it
wasn't for you was medical in like
Michael Schneider life Kevin or s yeah
[ __ ] he didn't that Michael Stipe like
really impressed it like this has been
going on for like a week right less
famous people like Josh GAD is reading
children's books to kids have you seen
that but you know hope for her cold
heart
none of it just re yeah Michael Stipe
singing at her as if you know who's just
guy who sang it's the end of the world
as we know it and I feel fine he was
like that's me in the corner that's me
in the corner to Michael you know
because I married clerks guy so he got
on Instagram and he didn't mention any
of us by name he just mentioned God but
here's what he's praying for God
explained it and here's the point I said
we were gonna circle back again about
screaming into the void everyone be
online and saying look at me I'm still
here what's the biggest look at me then
a guy who says I'm going to have a
conversation with my god to put it on
social media and force everybody to
watch him at work maybe I lost track of
this he filmed himself praying yes out
loud yes is something like a [ __ ]
priest 1970
[Music]
man-boy we did some really silly [ __ ]
when we were kids I mean we were forced
to do some [ __ ] yes I'm some sillier
than others and some kids got a worse
deal than others that's true
I gotta be honest with you I enjoyed it
all I never really you know the touching
me but like [ __ ] serving on like
being an altar boy and [ __ ] ringing
bells yeah cuz i steeped it and I was
like oh my god I'm [ __ ] this is my
job for God unless you're performing in
front of a crowd just the key Ralph it
was never shot it was about me look man
I'm on stage you have to look at me
because I'm standing with Jesus right
behind my back and that's what Bieber
did this week and it made me furious and
we talked about people trying to stay
relevant and how do I do it do I sing a
song do I read a children's book
whatever he had the audacity to say I'm
gonna pray y'all and this is this is me
talking to God everything's gonna be
okay cuz I'm gonna talk to guys like if
you are the least bit pious isn't that a
personal relationship you're supposed to
have with the Almighty and that's a
thing you do do you really want to pray
in public on Instagram and make everyone
watch here I'll give the benefit of the
doubt like that is you want to listen to
it first then you can comment yeah you
want to hear his prayer if he was doing
like let's say we Ralph he just did the
our Father because that's something when
you're in church they make you all do
together yesterday and maybe he sang it
and threw in a little of his [ __ ]
who's and should they put that would be
acceptable right I mean you'd be a
little like what an odd choice of song
to sing but still people are used to
that that's the kind of praying you can
hear out loud and you don't judge other
people for well you can't judge them for
it being like the prayer know if I can
imagine mercy if you're one of those
people right you're judging right but
you can't be like oh like you're
supposed to keep your prayers to
yourself and [ __ ] like that that would
be acceptable mm-hmm what you're saying
is what I'm about to hear is not him
singing the our Father see how you feel
about it rankled me this is like the
kind of thing they do in like a church
like the
as you see on Sunday and being where the
guy closes his eyes yes Jesus I pray to
you this is a televangelist moment for
Justin Bieber higher here we go get
ready kids I was going to say a quick
prayer and if you guys want to agree
with me cool if you don't it's also cool
you don't have to believe anything I
believe too you know we have far more in
common than we don't what God I believe
in you Christ my Redeemer you run my
life but I got throw this disclaimer out
there anyway
Jesus please just for the people who
don't believe that you are what I
believe that you are but I'm gonna
concede to them is called benefit of the
dizzle your Lord this sizzurp is coming
your way in the way of prayers like if
you if you're gonna pray out loud do
like commit that you get off the [ __ ]
pick a lane you can't be like I believe
with everything I have but just in case
you don't believe that's cool I'm look
I'm I try to be as diplomatic as I can
at all times yes you do but in your
praying you're kind of drawing a line by
the act of doing it yeah you're pretty
much announcing you're waving a flag
right yeah the [ __ ] you start waving
right after that big old Christian flag
is the white flag going hold on please
or not yeah it's not for everybody for
other people don't believe in this just
tune it out it's really [ __ ] but for you
Christ my Redeemer I've tattooed you on
my body
no disclaimers here we go he said a
little prayer 54 seconds if he starts
now that's all we got people who are in
this together just trying to figure this
whole thing out so I'm gonna say a
prayer for the world again doesn't make
me any better because I'm praying it's
just I just think prayer makes people
come together and so I'm gonna I'm gonna
pray make a dirty joke does prayer make
people coming in because if so
some people it does um blessed is he who
comes in the name that's really that's
what brethren and sistren cistern I
think that's what they used to say here
we go it sounds like the prayers bounced
again up again it's a lot of build up
man
here comes not better than anybody by
the way just because he's praying know
you've heard the chorus folks it comes
the hook god we thank you so much for
this day and thank you so much that you
have everything in control you you know
the beginning from the end and you're
not surprised by this whole thing that's
happening God um we know that these
things don't come from you that these
things are unexplainable but God we
trust you in these times and we just ask
God that you would you would make this
go away as soon as possible God and we
just thank you so much for who you are
and we just ask that you would you would
give us more answers your name we pray
amen I mean I hate to borrow from an old
George Carlin bit but isn't isn't asking
God for anything presuming upon a
friendship we talked about it last time
you asked him to change like this is a
lot of mixed messages he's like you know
everything beginning to the end you're
not surprised but this didn't come from
you and you're like whoa you're
surprised do even though you're not and
you know everything but you didn't make
this I got nothing out of it other than
him shirtless praying for was he
shirtless I believe he was yeah maybe
that's why my prayers didn't work
yeah get off my heart and chest it's in
a white blocks from wearing a free Excel
shirt [ __ ] I gotta go rip that shirt off
and [ __ ] like a rasler and scream to
the heavens I love him say guess what
I'm buying a hundred thousand
ventilators with all my [ __ ]
despedido money and I'm gonna start
handing them out hospitals everywhere
and just [ __ ] save save your prayers
for whatever you do with your your that
your preacher pal that you hang out with
and just do that there that would make
me respect him more
I don't mind it when people like I'm
praying for you I'm like
but I don't like I'm not calling them
liers but I don't think they are like
specifically cuz you know you got to
shout me out by name in those prayers
we're gonna name checks God be like the
ender got my world he got his own romper
room there you know there's a c-can I'm
writing for Kevin and Ralph and Jason
and Jordan no [ __ ] made untoward
remarks about single man down forgets I
have need Kevin um I can look at the
menu
I can't mock faith because I still even
though I don't you know here do it
anymore I don't mock thank you if he was
no no I'm not saying you do I'm just
clarifying for those out there they're
like how dare you cuz I'm not we're not
modern faith I'm [ __ ] Bieber right if
anything and I'm not mocking I'm sitting
here going like if he truly believes
this stuff and he might at this point
he's had a rocky [ __ ] road right
mm-hm and most folks who have a rocky
road find refuge in the bosom of the
Lord yes I was raised in the bosom of
the Lord no not given a choice told that
this [ __ ] was reality from the time I
was a child up and stuffs right I've got
a perspective now of both sides
yes stuff like that I tell you like it'd
be tough to maintain my faith in the
face of social media you know it was
much easier to believe everything I did
when there weren't you know other
avenues people go on home I lived in a
Catholic world so right and there were
non Catholics but they were Protestants
and [ __ ] you know Methodists and
stuff mm-hm you know nobody really
challenged your worldview right even
though I had relatives again didn't go
to church they weren't like you know it
was just kind of accepted I didn't come
to the Lord because I was like I need
your [ __ ] help I'm [ __ ] hit rock
bottom I don't I'm out of control or
anything like that it was just the thing
and if faith helps those people get oh
god oh I'm all for it my point is always
this having had that faith when I was
kidding and now I tell I'm a different
person and stuff I don't like mock it
I'm not saying I'm right they're wrong
whatever I [ __ ] I just got to a
different place I do sometimes miss
that level of like just certainty yes oh
my god it was what a simple world it was
like I I i you know be some it just life
be so much easier if i was still that
kid critical thinking is a burden so yes
most people don't like to do it they
much would rather be told by someone
what to believe in how to behave because
it relieves you of all the
responsibility we tell you something
right now we're going about this all the
wrong way if this made us kids on
something if he praying for us mm-hmm
and it works coronavirus eventually goes
away and because i might click as he
prayed first uh-huh he might be a
[ __ ] prophet oh you're my conduit
except we could start asking him to ask
his friends above war [ __ ] like money
he's cracked the code we all want like
what if we were all like we all want to
be you we want what you have and stuff
does he bless tattoos yeah maybe like
rethink some of the bad decisions you
made but we all want the opportunities
that you were given and run the race and
see what happens wasn't [ __ ] does he
then pray for everybody really like wait
a second if there's like a billion
Justin Bieber's do I'm not him I stand
down and then he doesn't pass on our
prayers and then means gordon-gordon
prayers and then and in Anniversary
Euler paper just in a moral and just
universe yeah I like are we allowed to
like you take him and make him talk to
the Lord we have to if he's if he's
brave enough to go out there and say I
can literally speak to God like he just
put his life on the line Ralphie they're
a bunch people Abner was like I want to
talk about God my whole life and I've
never heard I'm apparently you can if
you're on the desert island one guy has
a walkie-talkie
oh man you want that walkie Tommy's
gonna run into his [ __ ] dirty birdie
mister man and Annie [ __ ] knows him
and he Wilkes he's gonna [ __ ] a duty
give me your cockadoodie praise we
better call that cockadoodie Christ for
me right now wondering you think does he
think God's one of his Instagram
followers is that why he had to post it
so God would hear the prayer if you
believe
shouldn't you be able to say that in a
broom closet and God will get to get the
same message delivered right you don't
have to put it on Instagram we reach him
are you bumping into the false piety of
him doing it in public
absolutely that's that's what but weed
to be fair we do that for a different
religion all the time you mean we pret
Marvel like crazy we suck it's a [ __ ]
it could do no wrong even the ones that
like you know give me more more helpings
can fight and not because you're like I
want to jump there just because you like
this [ __ ] [ __ ] tasty yes um maybe
that's how he feels about maybe that's
his Marvel I got you you know Jesus
alright so that's his [ __ ] thing he's
like you got Star Wars
I got like you know Jesus in the 12
apostles in the Bible look whatever
works for him I just think it's it's
it's so sad that he has to do that in
front of an office it's almost got a
cloth clean you were like no you know
just but pungency King aspect of it it's
like there there are hardcore Christian
entertainers throughout the business
yeah you got your chris pratt's and
people like that who are true believers
but they rarely make a thing about it
you know Chris Pratt remember when I'm
Art Attack and I was like hey man like
[ __ ] like I met him once sweet
[ __ ] kid and stuff and apparently
like it came out germ arts acted like
you know he had like I was a touchstone
for him right his teacher at one point
it said here look at this guy made a
[ __ ] black-and-white movie and stuff
and you know so that made him think hey
maybe it was no you know that's it it's
not like I helped him right he was
inspired by my [ __ ] like I was inspired
about he met Richard Linklater right um
when I'm a heart attack he was like he
put up a nice like tweet like oh my god
I'm Bob a bomb there's some truncated
version of that yeah I'm praying for you
[ __ ] important poor star-lord he got
beat up oh my god they [ __ ] dragged
him prayer why don't you [ __ ] like
you know oh my god and and I felt so bad
for the poor dude man like he didn't
like dude took a few seconds to be like
I'm like I'm gonna throw a [ __ ]
silent pill some good wishes like cuz I
remember distantly watching one of his
movies it made me think maybe I can
teach anything but I did some teachers
rats everybody nice to you again oh my
god now I'm speaking of which keeping it
relevant that's an old story and [ __ ] it
just happened this week to Wonder Woman
[ __ ] you saw this [ __ ] story yeah so
gal gadot gig not good dude good good
Godot is a good combination of both gal
gadot gal gadot yeah Wonder Woman
herself boom boom puts out a [ __ ] not
bad but yeah that woman isn't she
you know she was a common [ __ ] I got
a bunch of famous friends I'm gonna have
him do a [ __ ] we are the world
everyone sing a line to imagine yeah I
don't post on social media maybe lift
spirits yes an asteroid donation was the
song tickets but that's like this goes
out to you yeah [ __ ] we're on this
together
and oh my god man like you're so rich
she got dragged to [ __ ] like she can get
cancelled but people were like bad
[ __ ] look we're dumb and just went
after her and all her friends because
they were singing a song yeah in their
mansions here's the thing and this is
where I draw the line some people will
hear that story and hear me agreeing
with you saying well Bieber's doing the
exact same thing I beg to differ I think
in times of great crisis the most
comforting thing you can give people if
you're an entertainer is to do what you
do it's that consistency we were talking
about before right
I love seeing gal gadot and Will Ferrell
and everyone else sing a song because
they're entertainers and that's what
they're doing and they're giving it free
of charge as a little attaboy keep your
chin up kind of situation Josh GAD
reading children's books Michael Stipe
singing his songs at least they're doing
what they do to pitch in right
apparently nobody lives at this
apparently no that's gonna ring forever
door if Bieber was singing a song I
would be like okay it's not for me
that's not I'm not his audience but
maybe is his audience we'll get it some
joy out of that in these uncertain times
right but it was the fact that he was
now going to be
pasta pasta tossing that's not a word
proselytizing I guess
anyway just out there and and and then
like you said the caveats of you don't
have to believe and I'm not better than
you just because I'm gonna be talking to
God right now continue like I have a
little conversation but I'm not better
than you that's like you're so desperate
just stop it
it's the I mean again I'm a disclaimer
fool you I've been doing it before I'm
like I'm never I never want to [ __ ]
offend anybody but you know it's just
funny to hear somebody who's just like
everything is because of you you are my
guiding light I live my life down for
you but you're not real these people
over for a second buy my records for
your grandma ok back to with just as
much fervor and passion good intention
with intentions I thought his intention
seemed good give the man no quarter
nothing you know I'm taking no given so
in the [ __ ] Bieber gal like oh she got
the worst of it for sure she really I
think in terms of whether was warranted
or not yeah yeah I don't think I don't
think that very story was much louder I
know I know that's what I'm talking
about that's why we're here Kevin to
tackle the stories no one else is
tackling I I wish we were recording that
[ __ ] one in the morning we could have
broke the news that were probably gonna
get to right now man the news about big
lost Ralph yeah sounds like you did a
deep dive already I couldn't help it man
but we're talking about do the set up
and you say the thing at this point in
the show we talk about people who left
us way too soon but left behind bodies
of work will enjoy for many years to
come
it's time for the Tinseltown stick I'm
sorry before I should have just hit it
but it's like watching a brilliant
surgeon open up a cavity take out a
heart and replace it with a heart
and [ __ ] save a life so butter good
unbelievable
I blew it by [ __ ] blowing you this is
good fast and loose and now another and
now another edition they will be missed
[Music]
most you can hope for is to die in your
sleep is that what happened eventually I
mean do we know for a fact it doesn't
know it never [ __ ] occurred to me is
that great would it have been if that's
what happened yes because that's he
literally told us that he's the best way
anyone ever hoped for it's a haunting
[ __ ] line it sure is I heard that
first at first when I was like 9 or when
he released the song and probably in the
70s late 70s and that line is stuck with
me for the better part of 40 years the
best that you can hope for is to dine
asleep never mind all the metaphors that
the song contains that line is [ __ ]
truth you'll never hear a truer thing
said by a total stranger in your life it
is absolutely true and that's why I'm
glad he gave him his last swallow yes
yeah in this song in the song yes
because he that man earned it with that
piece of wisdom he did he drank down my
last swallow you better swallow again
stop this sexually harassing strangers
[ __ ] I've gotta get some help for me
going up my dick in my pants now I want
to stay on the railroad they threw me
off the laptop bad for talking can't
afford no cars and
uber ain't been had been different prism
the the great
Kenneth Rogers yeah
aka Kenny it was friends they killed
Kenny bastards died now I'm obsessed
with finding out if he died in his sleep
all they said was he was in hospice care
at home surrounded by his family when he
passed that's what I read I hope he was
asleep I hope so too it would have made
him absolutely right you know although
even if he didn't die in his sleep but
doesn't make him wrong
no it just would have been sad that even
more did her sweet more right he never
didn't get the one thing that he thought
he should have had my yeah Kenny Rogers
as some people I want the [ __ ] didn't he
sell chicken yeah I did that but he did
a lot of other things and he did he to
borrow from [ __ ] uh Richard Marx
Richard Marx go [ __ ] crazy builder
off lately it's so much when somebody
was like who are you and he's like I I
did the songs that your your girl [ __ ]
to before she met you like something
[ __ ] Jason musicianship to borrow
from the great Richard Marx Kenny Rogers
like wrote all the songs that your
grandma probably maybe your mom got
[ __ ] - my mom got [ __ ] - those game
right or something like Craig
grandmother - people forget very few
artists have crossed over in a minute as
many different genres as Kenny Rogers
did start out as a folk singer with the
new crystal minstry the new mint new
Christy Minstrels
that's at new Christy Minstrels I'm not
even drunk is that who he did just no
that was Kenny Rogers than the new
generation or the next generation or
whatever yeah yeah yes so it goes from
folk then to rock with that song and
then from rock into country and then
country crosses over into pop and
mainstream and becomes a multi-genre
threat the guy was a monster 2124 number
one hits Kevin Smith 24 over 50 million
records sold
it's an insane
[Music]
most people know it as the Big Lebowski
song yeah first edition psychedelic acid
rock they did not something you think
wait action wrote it or somebody like
somebody equally sort of not unexpected
it was already a thing and they did it
covered yeah he look at him he looks
like young Santa Claus from Santa Claus
is coming in - yeah put one foot in
front that beard yeah and got mad skills
yo I look forward to envy all the women
that are about to find out some mad
[ __ ] skills my friend as soon as this
virus passes can the great Kenny Rogers
ladies and gentlemen he left us actor
singer songwriter live performer I saw
him like once in Vegas my soon-to-be
ex-wife was taking her parents to Vegas
to celebrate their anniversary and they
were huge Kenny Rogers fans mm-hmm and
so we went to see him at the Orleans
Theatre which if you know anything about
Vegas not one of the high-end casino
showrooms in town he was on the other
end of his career but unrecognizable do
the plastic surgery he had put himself
through towards the end of his life but
still had the voice and still could sell
and still could sing and deliver for an
audience and I gotta tell you I was
impressed and him and Dolly right there
yeah islands in the stream of course
around for [ __ ] rock in a second
story song this and coward of the county
and other stories yeah
[Laughter]
I love reading people's faces
by the way so if you don't mind my see I
can see you're out of this song bottle
flesh bottle right because with me is
man Tina that's the winner boys and
girls if you were if you had man teen on
Babylon bingo man team is the winning
word for today's edition congratulations
all our winners you get your lecture
prizes at the door if this song doesn't
call to mind your dad you didn't grow up
in my house yeah same this is a song
that like I know got my [ __ ] old man
laid my mom was always singing this is
my dad singing plug in I was talking
about a livestream today they make like
brunch and she played that albums on the
high five oh yeah grace would be like Oh
done you decorated my life right fat
ones eating there I'll take him to the
movies who took me see six-pack that's
funny Kenny Rogers took me in many
movies yeah Kenny Rogers movie career of
course my parents song was through the
years don't I can't play this because
I'll cry let me do that was there their
special song
this song makes me cry thinking about my
wife she it became like our kind of
unofficial thing we one day we can't
sing because this used to be a parent
song yep you know I remember my parents
sang to each other and be like Oh
they've known each other for a minute
that make sense but like one day kicked
in the door Chazz been passed everything
he said
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm too fast on the music lady anything
you want we got it all go yeah
Spotify is it off how hard are they
getting hit today Kenny Rogers
Department broke the Internet everybody
so you know what that's us go on
everything man forget everybody are you
kidding no there's a whole dad people we
say everybody we're like Kenny who was
already dead didn't tanks just play him
in a movie um is that did sue change
sample him no oh yeah when your dad's
heroes die dude yeah that's when God's
fall you're up next
this guy was [ __ ] famous everywhere
one of those famous people in the
[ __ ] world TV shows movies records
concerts he had 96 wives
yes he was like Henry the eighth he just
went wife after wife man he was a big
believer in love like that song you know
uh not through the years love but love
stick around through the years
Louie it's you watch your step found
somebody yeah but she well he did it no
he's like it could be like [ __ ] you I
did do it through the years each one of
those women I was with for multiple
years put him together no it's like the
lifetime of love two's a year the two is
a plural [ __ ]
so there I win so even if he's with his
wife for two years through these years
or two through the years just not
specific it's applicable genius because
it's applicable you just have to be with
somebody for more than one year two
years then you can sing that so that's
true and he
could literally have stood onstage and
if some [ __ ] like me it would have
been like I'll give you [ __ ] say is
[ __ ] when you're the voice for the
one you're out of are you'd be like
first off on him you know if I wrote it
check Wikipedia I probably did I was on
his I'm sorry number two number two I
was married multiple years to all the
women that I was married to so ideal
years [ __ ] yes sure [ __ ] ass down
silent bill I'm a [ __ ] icon your
parents [ __ ] to me you probably hear cuz
of me [ __ ] that piece of [ __ ]
stop eating that head he'd sit my ass
down and my parents would be like you
know you like it so much
[ __ ] that embarrassed us oh it would
never be Tiger embarrasses it would be
like this cold like Florence so much
[ __ ] trouble
they wouldn't so much terrifying ice mmm
like the humiliate you have you
embarrassed us which still like is me to
this day like that's the more than
anything else like being embarrassed my
kryptonite and embarrassing others with
your behavior are you being embarrassed
which is worse disappointing those that
love you or being publicly humiliated
personally because I had the same thing
but for me was the shame of my parents
was the crippling part it wasn't that I
did something stupid in public maybe
that change is when you know what it is
like my parents my dad was always very
private like you know you don't talk
about should she the shades go down at
five o'clock and a big looking on her
house as if anybody wanted to you know
and what's they were very Vegas what
happened in this house stays in this
house you should so yeah I don't know
where I [ __ ] I don't know I guess
there's a part of me that's because if
that bugs you you put yourself in a
weird career where every time you step
out in front of people you're running
the risk that the thing you're most
afraid of who could possibly happen and
that weird
um Jennifer I do I don't snap but like
that's the thing that like will be out
someplace and like you become your
parents when someone does something that
embarrasses you by association that
makes you feel bad
yeah and it's not like you know like I
get like no I'm not saying like [ __ ]
I get all out but like you've been
around with me on public people are like
holy [ __ ] yeah it's hard to move through
a space with you and like Jennifer gets
tight about that whereas I'm like are
you kidding me like there's like this is
this is what I literally dreamed about
the world we're [ __ ] people recognize
me and say oh my god I like what you do
and I got time for everybody the hell
bought tickets the one thing or another
and sure Jennifer is not that person
she's like we're out like can I just see
dinner with you can't and you know
sometimes people like I mean Jennifer's
thing is like you know you don't see it
from my perspective
they don't even see me she was like a
lot of them pushed literally past me to
get to you mm-hmm
like I'm if I'm thought of it all you
have to be like oh and this is my wife
Jennifer and so but as soon as they need
somebody to take a selfie like they'll
jam a camera right in my pants
so Jennifer at a certain point like just
walks away
hmm and so somebody would be like can
you take a picture first and you know
she's walking like I got it that's how I
learned to take sometimes because so you
know there in the beginning when that
started happening this going back like
10 12 years ago when everyone had a
phone on a camera phone on him all of a
sudden right like that was real like a
point of contention where I was like you
that's I can't do that like you know
that's that's who pays our bills like
you can't walk away don't you can't make
anybody feel like they were wrong for
coming up to me brave to even [ __ ]
make that thing and Andrew and I and I
like also it's like [ __ ] that's free
publicity that [ __ ] photo goes
everywhere
everywhere that photo goes that people
go like you know what that guy's a good
guy that's also your brand you're a man
of the people you know let's kind of
always been who you are it's easy it's
literally what I wanted right like
anytime I take a pictures I'm gonna like
I'm sorry about those are you kidding me
that means like the plan is working like
come here right and that's how I call
coronavirus touching every [ __ ]
stranger it's been an airport that I've
met and all the shows and [ __ ] but yeah
man like there that was like first time
but that would embarrass you which he
walked away and yourself distant you're
like you're because the person who came
up to me mmm is embarrassed right
because they're reading a vibe of like
I'm imposing yes and my vibe is like you
could I could be having sex with my wife
and you could be like I'd be like
autograph oh my god
come on over this is why I did it all
[Laughter]
but Jennifer doesn't quite have the same
and it's not like she hates fans would
that's not it but she's like like we
show we want some of you that's hers
alone yeah and I'm like oh but you know
why we live in life we do because you
are right and like you know God forbid
like [ __ ] one day I say something
like [ __ ] him
you know all that Bieber talk about
prayer and [ __ ] that gets me cancelled I
can't even [ __ ] work and [ __ ] like
that and then and then also all those
people would stop asking for [ __ ] unless
they were like oh I'm gonna take a
picture with my [ __ ] room float in
his life for the powered wheel saw a
human disaster is a human freak or
something like that see the failed man
in the cage he had it all not really
oh yeah a little bit even that went away
and they don't know there's nothing
really good nothing looks back you laid
out a huge fall from grace but a medium
fall from grace look it's a local show
to see around just me well find somebody
is a bigger failure but right now that's
not possible
the irony is for him to be a failure you
can't really hurt him see
see hey in the cage like you [ __ ]
sell me like [ __ ] my god now you [ __ ] up
let me do it but anyway back to Kenny
yes he is now 181 what an amazing life
as we as I used to say on a show that I
used to listen to big bucket win huge
bucket a bucket of win there's a
cauldron of wind we're probably a sued
for all the music we're playing he drank
that cauldron down to its last swallow
yeah he kept going he was and he was
still touring when he passed he'd just
taken off like the last few months from
the road or the last year whatever but
he was doing a the gambler gambler souls
tour and figure right for the last two
years he'd been in hospice or something
good as little ago as 2015 2016 you can
go see Kenny mmm late 70s and stuff now
opportunities got my cousin D at like
sent it to her texted her 1:00 in the
morning she put like loves Kenny Rogers
and now this morning she got up and she
was so pressed punk she was like I never
got to see him rooms like that was one
of the two people I went see she's gone
the other you brought me to see we'd
gone see Dolly Parton but yeah man I
realized I too had never seen him what
was it like seeing him sound if you
close your eyes they sound great so it's
not a great great show 90 minutes Vegas
show then what's never run more than 90
minutes did he do just checked in to see
what condition or just yeah really yeah
how could he not write like this is hip
now many of you probably first heard me
back in the 60s when I had a little hit
it was not really what I'm used to doing
but out of out of step for what you know
me for from most of my career but this
is where I was back then and where asked
me know that's nuts
like many of you probably first heard of
me because of this song been rolling
clips I don't think I think he thought
it was more about him than the
Lebowski's
yeah yeah in that room he was probably
right because as I looked around I said
I might be the youngest person in this
room it wasn't a bunch of people that
seen the basket you know like this
really holds the room together Kenny
bunch of people like you decorated my
life Kenny
I got a six-pack for you yeah you're the
gambler they did like 98 gambler Bruce
game sure did it just he knew how to
gamble did you ever watch any of them
yes who did they follow the song maybe I
watched the hunt like did he play well
he was the gambler yeah the one on the
train who had the last wall yes he
swallowed everybody in that series of
films but so it was really the first
movie died maybe the rest of the movies
flashbacks to when he was lying I was
like The Adventures of the gamblers it's
like it was pre fall before well
prequels yes yeah it's kind of genius
yeah it's very Marvel it was wasn't
didn't one have Willie and Waylon and
Johnny Cash and Willie Tyler and Lester
in one of them that is I did I remember
seeing because my parents watched him so
I if I was in the room that's what we
watched we didn't have no fancy VCRs or
nothing
my dad loved Kenny Rogers I love my
parents - my mom - he's gone now mom's
still around them yeah mom I'm an orphan
I guess he was older than mom though cuz
mom is like 74 so he had mom by seven
years mhm he decorated all of our
[ __ ] lives were nice good one thank
you it could be a DJ yeah there's a
photo of magic FM verified okay Kenny
Rogers who decorated all of our lives
we'll be right back um I would have hit
the post right there he had four point
three still has monthly listeners here
on Spotify four point three monthly
listeners four point three million
monthly that's more it took several
tries before Kenny Rogers became a star
as a member of the new Christy Minstrels
in the first edition he earned a few
hits but
late 70s he started [ __ ] the charts
with his big old kenny rogers roaster he
began charting with a series of well
done middle-of-the-road song hey hey
spotify ain't wrong changeling what do
you mean
middle of the road yeah blurs middle of
the road yes we all agree that he was
right that [ __ ] the best you can hope
for it he's a prophet the man's a
prophet musically he was definitely
middle-of-the-road what does that mean
musician you can't judge i but i was in
the radio business whistling they had a
radio turn yes wasn't me maybe i'm
getting insulted for nothing middle of
the road me anything you've got the the
new cutting-edge music I got both oh
that's the young young uns like yeah and
then you got the old standard American
Songbook artists like Sinatra and Tony
Bennett that skews older and the
middle-of-the-road artists were those
who could pull from both camps and have
huge successes because they had a lot of
crossover audience was a compliment
yeah but but it's considered sort of
safe music because it appeals to a great
number of people rather than polarizing
music that may be more interesting or
experimental or different this was sort
of standard fare was middle-of-the-road
Rodgers crested with Lucille yeah hey
country chart top read picked a fine
time to leave me Lucy you remember Ruby
too Ruby don't think you're loved they
list
he said Dottie West duets Dolly Parton
duets song of the year he won for
Lucille and for the gambler a parade of
subsequent Smash Hits [ __ ] if can you
imagine be so lucky that's written in
your [ __ ] mmm and they didn't write
this when he died is when he was alive
right but somebody can write about you a
parade of subsequent Smash Hits coward
of the county yeah
everyone considered him coward of county
but in that song he just
kept it tight cuz he promised his dad a
prom mr. dad not to do things you had
I'd walk away from trouble when I could
but it don't mean you're weak no if you
turn the other cheek that's what his
dad's but he was like sometimes a man's
got a puncher that's being a man that's
the point of the song is but only
because they messed with his girl that's
the only reason he ever betrayed his
father he had to do the right thing by
his woman what happened somebody Atkins
boys whoever from down the road started
messing with Molly or wherever she was
and so he so he's like [ __ ] that I gotta
put a stop to this kind of nonsense
[Laughter]
movie already so Kenny Rogers every
Western that's pretty compelling really
listen there's a whole whole third act
is about how he takes your rage and his
girlfriend sound like good you never
stand up for yourself and then did some
boys from the neighborhood some brothers
get together and I think they at least
don't don't
I think they sexually harass her if not
just them going [ __ ] your petticoat not
assault her I mean so it gets chipped
gets bad
oh and one of them so and so Donnie's
got a [ __ ] snow they call it in comics
they fridge his girlfriend so to speak
had to use her to make his story
interesting yes look write danger yeah
yes they did in comics yes reference to
Col Rainier yes I believe found his
girlfriend for stuffed in the fridge
major disaster or somebody killed yeah I
think so anyway off topic back to this
so he it's big kids late it's like death
wish
yes kind of it's a country and western
death wish right except it don't kick in
till the third act yeah so he goes out
there and his whole thing is like I'm
sorry and he promised his dad he
wouldn't do [ __ ] because his dad was an
outlaw and he died died poorly
we mean in the middle of fighting sure
yeah sorry yeah I think those were his
dying words as he was all bolted it up
promise be son not dude things I've done
walk away from trouble when you can now
don't mean you're weak if you turn the
other cheek why don't you play it all
right good I'm trying to find it man are
they gonna let us put this on the
Internet music yeah we're not no we're
work that's literally a review of an
artist its history yeah fair use Kenny
Loggins no wrong Kenny Kenny Loggins
listen to the sequel song I'm alright
I'm not alright from Caddyshack - right
it was literally the best thing to come
out cash cheque - it's a really good
song but it's a wonderful song that
references the first song like it's a
[ __ ] cool sequel song uh-huh very few
of those in pop culture there's a gopher
dancing to this one to see that he talks
about being the ball time has taught me
anything you've got to learn to be the
ball and then there's no line where he
says in the beginning he's extended all
right so he references that [ __ ] song
it is it's a it's a brilliant [ __ ]
song for a way better
Caddyshack - than they thought if they
actually cave yeah oh my god it's a good
song anyway but you know one thing at a
time let's talk about the deals
decisions - Donnie here we go
[ __ ] story song master ladies Kenny
Rogers still have a little more time to
hit the post
Bobby 78 degrees out there - time
I've got to identify the station too
long for me isn't mom really alright
minutes then I got a really and I really
gotta go
I mean [ __ ] this I shouldn't have
brought it up nevermind about the kid
he's the coach
[Music]
Kenny's his ankle his uncle the
narrator's relationship to him so he's
dying in prison and he gets to say some
[ __ ] to his kid got a decade of living
hard living Tommy wasn't in prison his
dad was he should wrote a song about how
time your perspective time is screwed
like right I'd like at the coronavirus
on [ __ ] day it is no point anymore
every weekend
[Music]
[Music]
now let's skip the grody part about
people kidding attacks come in but wish
it could have been something less like
they [ __ ] shot Tommy's dog and that
we got a job wicks in I know this
motivating factor for Tommy in this
situation was the the mistreatment of
his girl I know but I'm saying like with
I know he's the Old West Kevin this has
happened like that if he's a
middle-of-the-road artist nowadays you
go for the dog yeah it's true cuz
everybody's got a dog right you know
took the last roll of toilet paper off
the shelf
yeah alright so I'm gonna skip the sad
part and get to the [ __ ] turnaround
man you gotta play the lead in no comes
to him she comes to Tommy and tells them
why it's depressing that it feels like
death wish I know but let's just
Audrey's father's dying words but
something bad happen and that's why it's
gonna do but I want to hear how flips is
oh sorry
I don't want to see somebody hurt so I
can have enjoyment but I do like stories
of personal growth and this is
technically one of those it is so I want
to get to the learn how to do with own
tax personal growth yeah audit ten and I
went down the column filling in the
numbers and the letters and the stars
stars stars on your tax form you're
getting audited I thought that [ __ ]
looks real good
I sure felt creative but then I wound up
getting audited back
in July promise me certified public with
someone that like has a commercial legit
and Coby Meijer two lawyers but H&R H&R
Block
you promised me Tata jewel Rock H&R
Block they know what they're doing it
reasonable rates because my fours full
of stars
alright back to the real third hour just
to jump back into the story he wants to
confront the guys and you know he
[ __ ] went to the barn [ __ ] it looked
at him on then he's like a [ __ ] he's
gonna leave do the right thing I'm one
of them says lookö y'all uh cuz he's a
Carroll County no no they say that but
his intention has changed well before
they even say that they don't even know
what they're doing they don't he's like
he's about the king's men their ass
really he goes up and he locks the dole
thank God you put it into a common frame
of reference a current one as well he
locks the door and then turns around
again they thought he was leaving but he
came into that room knowing exactly what
he was going to do question
yes of logic how do you lock swinging
saloon doors I'm not sure anybody watch
over-the-top saloon may have gone the
next step it had an actual door on the
coward of the county has gone nuts I
mean this is a story of a mass shooting
essentially I don't think shoots the now
in retrospect he might just beat them up
he'll kill them I don't believe he kills
them all let's find out it's a mass
beating mom and dad they lost their
lives walking in Crime Alley in
retrospect why would they walk in place
called crime scenes or oh there
and quick forget the dinner they don't
bury the lead on that one put it right
in the street me and my parents were too
flashy wealthy to be walking down that
Street and technically it wasn't a
street it was just an alley so what the
[ __ ] were they doing there let's dig a
little deep
get him probably trying to score some
[ __ ] horse yeah son alone Oh sad
tragic right there's [ __ ] way man
you think the Joker was dark step aside
a relic on childhood orgies and smack
alright so here's the OG [ __ ] Batman
even though Batman you know before this
[ __ ] right still this country western
Batman twenty years meaning since he was
ten thirty years old at this point he
was 10 when he started so sure you're
like oh well you skip the middle part on
his 30th birthday is all the information
we need to do the simple equation but
from Tommy's perspective maybe he means
this whole [ __ ] life no because he
was fine until he was ten really his dad
scraps when he was a kid a little kid
and then he stopped all that nonsense
once dad set him straight through life
[ __ ] grade school high school telling
people hey man I promised my dad not to
do dads alive you're just a [ __ ] you
won't [ __ ] your little [ __ ] [ __ ] but
also I promised my dad I wouldn't get
beat up bleeding on the linoleum here we
go
this is where [ __ ] gets metal the coward
coward this is where the name comes
ironic oh there goes coward of the
county likewise you chicken [ __ ] like
quite the opposite he killed the room
full of brothers locked his somehow
figured out a way to lock swinging SWANA
I call a tall guy shorty it's sort of an
ironic nickname here we go folks
batten down the hatches [ __ ] Tommy's
about to go as ralph said Kingsman on
their ass is the song about that as he
hated them there's this is the Herschel
East Coast West Coast worse was the beef
the country beef rewrappers do you think
the Gatlin do a return song like [ __ ]
Kenny Rogers Roasters what he didn't say
is after that flight there was another
one we unlocked the door and found him
in the street there were six of us it
was only 1 a.m. we were driving a
covered wagon you went under the horse's
feet first we shot then shot him in both
arms and avoided anything vital then we
shot him in the toe because that won't
kill him either when we shot him in the
dick
you knew he was done it hurts real hard
[Laughter]
I I think if you just say that he fought
them then you can move on with the song
yes specifics we don't need a
blow-by-blow description of these
injuries the man sustained you can see I
read the medical report out loud in the
song that's how I fell my situation we
go because I mean it's not less is more
why would you just like why is this is
song son real teaches children unreal
[ __ ] like you can't go in [ __ ] with
bullies months and then the hole will
never [ __ ] with that guy jeez I guess we
won't wait for him when it's
and then jump in when he doesn't see it
coming or maybe will hurt somebody loves
because you know girlfriend your wife
who are you Tommy
Tommy who are you boy Tommy this simple
act turned the Gatlin boys from punks
and hardcore killers they slaughtered
the whole town because they were
publicly embarrassed they killed
everyone I cared about just see me
crying kept me alive in a world where I
don't know anyone alive in retrospect I
wish I had my father's last words I
should I was hexed ever since I broke
that [ __ ] bow to my old man now I sit
alone and say hello to strangers on tray
open for a swallow for them today in
their sleep which I help because I
poison that song will be so much better
if when [ __ ] turned around that it
changed up musically cuz it's still like
doo doo doo doo doo doo doo and he's
going like Tommy killed everyone and do
dude it would have been much better
[Laughter]
their condition was lacking like the
singing version of the dancing guy and
the money money boss but they were hurt
that says their manager somebody told me
oh really
yeah I think Josh are dr. Josh rash he
would know on the road told me like that
was their manager friend and I just
trust them in all things musical he
became hard that's hilarious that's part
of the band like if you're if you have
to pay them like per head that's part of
it he's in there and he'd be like what
each team is he playing like he plays
himself
he is the engineers the entertainment
it's a way to get a [ __ ] double check
I think that's how they instituted it so
he would finally get paid they were like
he's part of the band huh that's cool
and then it became I think I trust Josh
integrity he knows he knows music play
the end of song so I can leave I can't
leave without the denim wall this is
kind of prayer isn't it if you're
praying to the dev here if you're
talking to the dead that's a prayer is
it yeah if you're saying it out loud
you're saying it a bunch of fun a bunch
of people isn't he just be bring at this
moment he's a little look at me at this
moment like I promised your dad not to
do the things you had but he's saying I
promised your dad not to do the things
she'd done he's still yeah I've been
around I would have been like kr hey dad
and hat is mommy's right there right you
probably would have seen it sooner or
later
I need coke right writing credit oh my
god to be rich right now yeah
just a piece quarter of the coward of
the county the touch you know how much
[ __ ] it would still be paying bills
at this point yeah I'd be like you know
paid for this house me rhyming Tommy
yeah Tommy did Tommy because I said had
and dad run made that song better to be
fair could you imagine if you had this
thing it's like what done done things
you've done
[Music]
this is the big flip remember his dad
said son you don't have to fight to be a
man's rank 20 years later dance
[Music]
sometimes you gotta I got to tell you
right now I'm over here in the song when
I was a kid and I was like oh I don't
ever want to be a man oh [ __ ] cuz I know
as a kid I rarely have to fight but if
you're telling me sometimes as a man I'm
going to have to yeah Oh a bit mad man
so I've endeavoured my whole life to
that's why you were never a drinker
because you don't want to end up in a
bar cuz you knew what would happen you
have to lock a door it's true you know I
take some Gatlin Brothers down I never
heard of a stoner lounge where
everyone's start punching each other go
no who the [ __ ] are you nobody gets over
hit over the head with a bong my dad
that's that's puts put this in your
movie you need to do an old-time western
bar brawl stoners lounge doing the
stoners out there it's like half-ass but
ever what doesn't really isn't really
the hard snow would you guys do the back
east thank you
poo snow hair of the county who is from
Kevin Smith becki becki
everyone considered him the chronic who
closes a song in the 70s and 80s because
remember when we were kids songs would
fade out yeah you're right and then if
you ever saw him in concert then just
fade out if you watch them on American
Bandstand or [ __ ] like Soul Train
they just fade it out and they just keep
lip-syncing to the mic yes oh my god
four years and took me years to realize
big wide - um but I appreciate an artist
in the seventies eighties who's like no
this song is [ __ ] done put a button on
its bow around it boom
we'll miss you Kenny Rogers man [ __ ] was
a good song he's good story song I'm in
that Becky section we should we skipped
over probably good about I think it's
the ultimate motivation it's the one
thing that could get him to betray his
father's trust like a serious crime Milt
the John wick trilogy unless a good dog
but he was a killer anyway yeah but was
he he just needed a little shove that's
right this guy was a pacifist he was a
dyed-in-the-wool pacifist this song
though it's like I know he made his
promise to his dad and that's his like
[ __ ] that he'd [ __ ] sails on but it's
like they pushed him overboard they
landed in a lifeboat good night
everybody
- Ralph Garman you got a copy right
there all right I will for the garnish
don't you have to do premiums for your
Garmin people we've got a whole merch
section all kinds of March at belongs up
there I think that [ __ ] quote is got
push that you're gonna find in two years
you can be going through your [ __ ]
Instagram and somebody's gonna have a
picture of Abraham Lincoln up with that
quote my meme will have been stolen
better [ __ ] mean the [ __ ] out right
now that I'm telling you steal me mitt
before they mean I won't mean it well
there it is we got an announce for these
come from now I gotta go there it is
entertainment ends when Ralph says I'm
gonna go turn I'm gonna lock the door to
this office I'm gonna come back and beat
your ass the coward up [ __ ] accord there
it is man for [ __ ] uh ladies
gentlemen having a good time this
evening I can't thank you enough for
coming out but there is no show without
man sitting across me give it up for mr.
Ralph [ __ ] Garmin let's hear from my
Babel brother mr. Kevin Smith and that
is Hollywood babble-on for this week I'm
Kevin Smith I'm Ralph Garman map of the
[ __ ] off Kalakh everybody everybody wash
your hands
[Music]
this has been a production of Smaug Co
internet radio sir
only at SModcast calm